all right you guys probably heard about
this I think this is the coolest story
of the week the European Space Agency
their rosetta mission successfully
landed on the fillet comet I hope I'm
pronouncing that right I heard a
pronounced about a thousand different
ways this is a giant moving comet and of
course of course the conspiracy theories
are flying so we've got a little
something from the Guardian and then we
got a whole bunch more so this is
supposedly about a leaked email that was
sent to the Guardian the email allegedly
from a secret whistleblowing employee of
the European Space Agency accuses the
agency of blatant cover-ups and wanting
to land on the speeding comet and
attaches photos which claim to reveal
the true inner workings of Comet 67p now
we've got an excerpt from the email
itself comet 67p is not a comet some 20
years ago NASA began detecting radio
bursts from an unknown origin out in
space it would later be known that these
had likely come from the direction of
the now named comet 67p
it does show signs on its outside of
machine-like parts and unnatural terrain
whatever this object is it did not ask
to be found or scrutinized and of course
videos are popping up all over YouTube
where people claim that they know
exactly what's going on and we've got
one right here
guys I'm gonna read an email that came
out a while back check this out there's
something flying across the surface
these are brand new high-res images from
the European Space Agency and they
already knew as we look at this
particular section of the comet also
appears to be a tower with this shadow
and it actually looks like a rounded
structure to the right of it that does
it is not as distinguishable as that
white disc it would the shadow that's
flying across that surface okay that
kind of sounds like something I like his
accent by the way no brother but we've
got even more if you think that's not
enough that something's going on here
the European Space Agency will they
confirm that the Comets been making sort
of a sound or a song if you will let's
listen
alright the tunes not as catchy is the
sound and the song in battlestar
galactica and they were all here the
Cylons were all hearing that but that's
that is something and finally just to
put a little perspective on the size of
this freaking thing let's take a look at
how big this thing is compared to the
city of Los Angeles this is a big-ass
comet alright my two esteemed guests
I've given you guys a lot to work with
here
what do you think I mean that that white
thing on the comet that kind of looked
like a radio tower of satellite I
thought it was a photo from the probe of
the land no no no I don't think so don't
we think so then definitely spacecraft
yeah gotta be go via space yeah but when
you put all this together it's making
some weird sounds the picture kinda you
know the government doesn't like telling
us about these things I'm coming on
board you know you're not totally I need
a little more evidence but I have a
theory that the reason why one of the
reasons why US presidents hair tends to
go white within the first year of their
presidency is because that first year
they're sat down and told about all the
alien activity and they go insane and
they go total they're terrified in their
ear goes right what about plausible
deniability remember in Independence Day
when they when they found the aliens and
they told the president he said why
don't anyone tell me I think a plausible
deniability
oh never so they don't do that no they
no they don't think I think okay if it
is Oh fantastic we want to know more you
know we want to get in on this whatever
please leave it alone every time I go
breaking and I look at a sunset I swear
to god I'm gonna sound so insane I don't
care it's worth it I sit there I go
I could seriously be sitting here in
Chains like enslaved right now with like
like hovercrafts going over me and like
you know like on a chain please leave
the aliens alone I don't want to be
enslaved by a race of demons
you let it be let the comet go by let's
continue to live our lives I think you
make a very valid point there if aliens
come here first they have to destroy us
right and if we get there first we'll
destroy that is that pretty that's
pretty much go places yeah you're not
going for the Peace Conference yeah I
mean if we blow up of Earth that's the
only reason I'd leave Malibu you know
I'm not that I live there but I like to
go there yeah you know on a weekend yeah
like if the math was gone
then I yeah we have to go to space yeah
I just don't think we're going for any
other reason that we've completely
depleted our own resources absolutely
yeah so it's avatar we're going because
we need the unobtanium yeah bring
diamonds on Neptune I mean we're gonna
destroy anything we can get our hands on
so please just do it after I die do it
hold off another 50 60 years and then go
crazy so I'm completely on board that
wouldn't the government so we all think
that these are conspiracy theories or
you know area obvious periods 51 51 now
okay what's I'm thinking of club 57 or
what studio 54 or whatever it is that
the point is there's a lot of freaky
people there too what are the
government's like there's this idea that
the governments would never tell us and
that maybe they know for the last 20
years of they never but wouldn't it
behoove them actually if we knew that
there was other stuff out there and it
was coming here maybe wouldn't it maybe
unite us we always talk about how we're
so we all hate each other countries are
at war what did somebody if we knew
aliens are on the way we might go all
right maybe we should have kind of work
this [ __ ] out yeah that's a good thought
experiment like for sure that should
work but people freak out when there's a
new iPhone yeah you know I think they're
gonna freak out when it's like oh my god
I mean not only am I gonna want to tell
that person I never told how I feel
about them as the impending apocalypse
approaches I'm also gonna want to steal
that new iPhone that's a good point
because think how advanced their iPhones
from flash on the front for selfies at
this point oh my god I also would love
them I can't wait I would like for that
to happen I know you I know um so here's
what I think I think you're absolutely
right
I think that's adorable of you and I get
why that would be a good thing but in
the society we live in it doesn't matter
what country are in what culture you're
part of you know the first thing us
[ __ ] would say because our heads are
so far up our own asses they told
yourself you didn't believe in this guy
and you didn't believe in this religion
and you didn't you ate meat and you
drank mullet coffee and you did it you
did that it is a little day that's why
the aliens are gonna kill us
so we just know it would be every man
for himself right so we would end up
being just like a race to contact them
first and be like come on our team
because these guys over here yeah
everybody would turn against each other
more than they already are